big Thursday show this marks the end of
our I think forty fourth week in
quarantine that's what it feels like to
me anyway
I'm losing it I really am I'm just you
can tell the hair is all messy I haven't
showered losing it I haven't shaved in
six years no testosterone hey the point
is this everyone's bitching about
quarantine a lot of people tell me
they're gaining weight I have not gained
any weight not at all yeah what has
happened is all my muscle has been
replaced with fat my entire skeletal
structure has been replaced with fat the
weight of my clothing has been replaced
with fat my hair is now made of fat my
teeth made of pure fat I'm just a big
blob of fat I sit in a beanbag chair all
day look like a sad marshmallow melting
in the Sun well I think I've proven that
I I'm not making any sense anymore
completely losing my mind I do want to
entertain you quickly with something I
think you might enjoy it's a little
something that I used to do back at
Senate live when I was a writer to try
and entertain people late at night it's
a little thing I called
who stole the fudge who stole the fudge
so I'm gonna turn my back America and I
want you to say hey who stole the fudge
I turned my back fudge someone stole
fudge who would do that we kind of
[ __ ] would steal fudge I hope you
guys look if you want to find that guy
bastard
fudge taker you know I'll sign up to
help you get him come on oh come on
don't judge that that's a good comedy
bang who stole the fudge that's a
classic
it's a quarantine we're all working with
what we got
anyway oh my god I was Hitler for a
second I apologize I don't want any
trouble there it's an accident